hey david is there anyone who would run
against
trump in the republican primary instead
of letting him have the nomination if he
wants it
this is a great question the context is
that last week
former ambassador to the u.n nikki haley
said
even though at one point a few couple
months ago she was kind of critical of
trump she said
um if trump runs i wouldn't run in 2024
and if trump runs i would support donald
trump
i think most of the people right now
that are contenders
for the republican primary in 2024 would
get the hell out of the way and let
trump have it
just to mike pompeo trump's secretary of
state has mentioned
i don't even think pompeo is a candidate
but there's no there's no chance in hell
that pompeo runs
against donald trump if pompeo's
thinking about it and trump runs
pompeo's out of the way i don't think
mike pence would run against donald
trump that would be really weird
former vice president running against
the person they served under
don't think it's going to happen ron
desantis is being mentioned the
republican florida governor who's
horrible in every way he would not run
against
donald trump um josh hawley who was one
of the first to defiantly
and and and proudly uh opposing the
certification of the 2020 election
results he's not running against trump
ted cruz not running against trump
christie gnome the south carolina
governor she's a trump suck-up she's not
going to run against him lindsey graham
forget about it
uh rick scott uh i don't see
any of these people actually challenging
trump unless
something dramatic were to happen
um around the 2022 midterms i uh
i i think that the the people who would
stay in if trump runs
are the people who would be running
because they don't like trump people
like
mitt romney uh who else i don't even
know
um i i can't even think of anybody else
mitt romney types
are the ones that wouldn't get out of
the way for trump
because they are not trumpists
fundamentally and
i think that trump's 2024
future will be far more determined
by trump's physical health at the time
and whether trump's urge for revenge and
pettiness
override laziness and i think that
trump's spending four years at
mar-a-lago
the idea of of i mean i get you know the
the campaign
fuels his narcissism the crowds and the
speeches and the media coverage there's
no doubt about it
but at the same time he's not a
particularly healthy guy
he'll be close to 80 at that time i
think he will be relatively bored and
complacent
and it will really be trump who
determines
what happens in 2024 as of right now if
it
if it's trump versus romney today i
think trump certainly wins trump has the
support of the vast majority of the
republican party
but don't expect a challenge to trump by
anyone from within
the trumpian circle could could uh liz
cheney maybe challenge trump yeah maybe
somebody
like that uh condoleezza rice
i don't know i'm thinking out loud but
most of the people that have been around
trump are not going to challenge donald
trump
if donald trump decides to run one of
our sponsors is privacy.com they're
giving you five dollars when you sign up
for their completely
free service at privacy.com pacman i've
been using privacy for a little over a
year now you've heard me talk about it
before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman